tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fatti j e v e vi ricordate via
l'hai visto hunger games
qual è il tuo personaggio preferito il
mio vita il tuo sguardo c'è anche edward
in hunger games hanno fatto il via con
compiuti paio sta cosa non ci posso
credere come cazzo è possibile provare a
parlare inglese
palau fiori pac man è miss fa vj due
ormai youtube c'erano ed è beautiful non
ci allarghiamo è non ho detto beautiful
mai nella vita e ora lo aiuti full my
name is mi bobbie jo durie norma youtube
channel
ma c'è anche l'italiano ma veramente si
prova a scrivere in italiano qualcosa
tipo ciao zio rivolti a cosa non sono
uccisi 16 mian 0 3 ma [ __ ] at last
ha confidenza intima conosci fa vigeva
adesso che gli chiede in italiano
sicuramente mi risponderà di sì
chiudi fi che dice le parole emis killa
j ax e fede non si può sentire siccome
c'è gente che dice che io copio più di
bahia allora vediamo cosa ne pensa più
di parma che ne pensi della gente che
dice che ti copio i b days in un paio
mentre on line al mondo anche lui penso
sia una cosa orribile coke ragazzi la
prima volta che ci troviamo davanti a
sua maestà e possiamo porgergli delle
domande porger di chi con la g maiuscola
di vino chiediamoli come arrivare a 46
milioni di iscritti come faccio ad
arrivare a 46 milioni di iscritti
quindi per avere 46 milioni di iscritti
devo avere una tra queste tre cose
cosa che il cazzo è successo per un
attimo sei stato curnuto non so è poi è
successo a marzia nel frattempo come sta
a marzia
ma macchina perfetta era intuibile dal
fatto che per un secondo ti sono
spuntate due corna quindi sei proprio
sicuro di sapere dove ecco dove sta
marzia in questo momento non lo sappiamo
però d'accordo ragazzi abbiamo scherzato
un attimo passiamo alle domande serie ma
io ti piaccio il bayern d'amore a in
febbrile
va bene si anche tu sei molto bello
molto amore quando vieni a trovarmi che
ti aspetto tutto nudo
l'uomo ha capito quando è ora di fare
sul serio
c'è una complicazione e che c'hai la
barba e questo potrebbe essere un
problema
e cosa vuoi fare una volta arrivato qui
registriamo insieme gang beast che è un
gioco figo che abbiamo fatto
va bene e poi e poi raggiungo 46 milioni
di iscritti perché ho fatto un video con
te e teneva a [ __ ] dal card se poi ti
offro una birra non so cosa bevi la
birra zio non mi plan brema ma non lo sa
lo shop lo scià pag
a che ora passi è un attimo st registra
fa mi venivano a finire questo video e
poi passiva bene addio più più di ti sei
fatto qualche canna nel frattempo ha gli
occhi rossi
infine guiot filmati non f
i ragazzi video se fossi la propra fisc
ma che figata dai va meglio se non ha
mai fatto bene però la porta i pop corn
e porta anche marzia perché sia marzo è
occupata ad annusare le scoregge del del
cane
che new limits al cui marzia forte dei
marmi blog the tenth ok altro come in
lui perché marzia è un lui non lo sapevo
la stai andando a prendere quella e
marzia senti gli occhi dolci
tocchiamoci nudi qui oggi da inventano
rettale sono venuti guardo e mi pento di
lady gaga qualche canzone di lady gaga
telephone
come ho scritto santo iddio telephones
cusmano scrivere e chiudi pie segue
nesli ti piace nesli
ma che cazzo c'entra né ma veramente non
pietro hanno detto ronald weasley son
passati da nesli a ronald weasley non ha
senso eccolo qua solo per te l'ho
portato e c'è anche harry là dietro ma
preferisci ron o harry potter mio film
preferito di harry potter dice
ovviamente harry potter è geniale e
geniale più di pai e il calice di fuoco
mi mancava tantissimo ora resiste anche
più di pai e i doni della morte
lo chiedono e per carità il mio film
preferito di piedi by una poltrona per
più di fare domande su di me vedere se
mi conosce qual è la tua serie preferita
di fa vj ha già quella volta che ho
fatto fast and furious con vin diesel è
stato divertentissimo a ganna
e che ne pensi di fa vj e la pietra
filosofale vj lorenzo costumi i cui anni
è certo stiamo parlando insieme
deficiente che ne pensi di lorenzo
ostuni e il primo palo vuoi limonare con
questo infanti amore ragazzi e devo
chiudere quel video delle cose urgenti
da sbrigare d'accordo ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla domanda fatidica che
faccio ad ogni singolo robot con cui
parlo hai visto anche hunger games
icoyote offerte nativo per il mio
personaggio preferito e vita il tuo
quale è perdente bravo bravo così ti
voglio così ti voglio perché ve lo
spiego la prima volta che ho chiesto sta
che ho fatto sto domanda un robot mi ha
risposto il mio personaggio preferito di
hunger games e bull ma lui l'ha detto
adesso quindi ha visto il mio video devo
andare adesso no no no no no ad c il
tutto deve andare meno posso andare i
temi partendo man and woman egregissimo
una persona del suo calibro e prevede
che già sta sudando esige una questione
di rilevante importanza prima della
suddetta l'uscita del sottoscritto
alquanto vero ma subito
ecco qua ma lei ragazzini che possono
correre qui il video è stato alquanto
imbarazzante però come facci un saluto
più di un pratico ma braccio il suo
pubblico
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
pollice in su è un abbraccio anche per
anche a pagine di facebook come
descrizione certificate non ci vediamo
al prossimo video e profit quale
dobbiamo chiudere col profit quindi
fammi un profit
no neanche inviato lo sapeva lui da
ragazzi